Density-independent pixels allow the
designer to create assets that appear
in an expected way,
no matter the resolution or
density of the target device.
A density-independent pixel is equal
to one pixel at the baseline density,
or 160 dpi.
They're often abbreviated dip or
just dp.
Don't confuse that with dpi
which stands for dots per inch.
So, what about at 320 dpi?
This is often called 2x.
Now, at 320 dpi, 1 dp is equal to 2 px.
So, working with density-independent
pixels helps you deal with crazy
situations like this where you may
have two devices with the same pixel
resolution but
differing amounts of space.
In this case, the tablet has a lot of
space and the phone has a lot less,
but they have the same pixel resolution.
We'll see how density-independent pixels
makes this much easier to work with.